you know
interconnectivity is great you know PR
presents unlimited opportunities for
financial markets and other things and
for medicine to solving problems of
disease uh you know scientists
cooperating ACR with each other across
oceans from around the world but in
geopolitics interconnectivity is
potentially very
destabilizing because now every place
matters you just can't cannot say that
Africa doesn't matter or southeast Asia
doesn't matter you know a crisis
anywhere can affect crises in other
places as never before because of the
way that the whole system is integrated
and let me just add right now that if
there was ever a military conflict of of
reasonable dimension in the Far East
between the United States and in China
it would have a catastrophic effect on
world financial markets to a degree that
we have not seen even in the Ukraine war
or certainly in the various Middle East
Wars of the past 25 years it would be
tantamount what to something like or
greater even than the 1929 crash yes
which had which had an effect on the
rise of Hitler for example in Germany
yes a gigantic convulsion yes and that's
why ultimately in terms of US policy a
the Asia Pacific is always the most
important because there's a realization
that any conflict there would be
high-end with missiles Hypersonic
weapons uh cyber Etc that would
destabilize world financial markets so
that even in the midst in the most
dramatic you know intense moments of the
Ukraine war there is a realization in
Washington especially in the Pentagon
that ultimately getting the Pacific
right is the most important thing and
getting the Pacific right means somehow
you know standing up for democracy in
Taiwan but not getting into a kinetic
conflict with China by any means is that
possible though I don't know I mean this
is going to play out maybe not just over
a few years but over a decade or two um
keep in mind that what what seems to be
starting to happen is that both sides
are edging into a post Cuban Missile
Crisis uh situation remember the Cuban
Missile Crisis of the fall of
1962 both superpowers stared into the
abyss and they were terrified at what
they saw and as a result after the Cuban
Missile Crisis you got a nuclear test B
treaty you got a hotline you got
strategic arms limitation talks you got
daytont ultimately all because both
superpowers were terrified of an actual
war and they didn't solve their problems
just like we're not solving our problems
with China but what they did do is they
built borders around them you know they
made it less likely that there would be
an accidental Hot War and I think that
is where the Biden administ ation and
where the Chinese regime are now hoping
to head towards I don't want to diss
what Patrick does at all you know he's
he's he's totally sincere and you know
he's a lovely Guy and um he treats his
cows very well and all the rest of it
but I just don't buy it if he is indeed
a carbon negative livestock Farm he's
the first one on earth because there's
been endless studies published in peer-
reviewed journals looking at the claims
of being carbon negative and none of
them so far have withstood the
scientific Pro process in fact there was
um a meta study published um at the
Oxford Martin School part of Oxford
University called grazed and Confused um
looked at 300 papers and it found no
instance anywhere on Earth of livestock
Farmers even washing their own faces in
terms of greenhouse gas emissions let
alone drawing down extra carbon
emissions and there's a fantastic amount
I'm not in any way saying that this is
what it's doing because but you know
there is a huge amount of jiggery pokery
involved in in carbon calculations of
what's going on under the soil and it's
just far too easy to make things look
right when they really aren't as for the
idea of well we could produce more
pasture fed meat I mean already
51% of the UK is is is producing pasture
fed meat and yet it produces scarcely
any I did calculations for for for sheep
for m and lamb and estimated that 4
million hectares of the Uplands are
being used to produce mutton and lamb in
this country and yet it produces just 1%
of our diet now 4 million hectares is
the same amount of as all the grain
growing in in in in the UK which
produces a very substantial part of our
diet it's a really profant form of land
use it's agricultural sprawl is what
we're looking at and this has an
enormous opportunity cost so if you look
at the hills of Britain they are almost
entirely bare there's scarcely any trees
above 200 M parts of inner London have
more trees per hectare than those Hills
have including in our national parks and
people think that's natural it's not the
altitudinal tree line in the UK is is
well over a th000 meters everywhere
except perhaps the top of the kangs and
one or two other very Rocky parts of the
Highlands almost everywhere else there
would be trees in the western half of
Britain it would be dominated by
temperate rainforest the reason there
are no trees
is primarily because sheep and cattle
selectively browse out tree seedlings
they're extremely nutritious they're the
things they like to eat more than
anything else and so unless you bring
your numbers down to ridiculously low
levels one sheep per 20 hectares no
trees are going to grow and that is the
most basic component of ecological re
regeneration trees returning to a
formerly forested landscape you haven't
got trees returning it's not
regeneration it's not regenerative
um and so you get all these terms banded
around this is regenerative farming you
know it's just like the word sustainable
it gets just tacked on to anything you
happen to be doing regenerative ranching
formerly known as ranching um it's just
just a word which people use and when
you look at the actual Wildlife which uh
Farms even wonderful beautiful
picturebook Farms like Patrick's support
it's a very thin selection of the
wildlife that could otherwise be living
there starting with the large Predators
you know we don't have wolves and links
in this country because livestock
Farmers insist that they don't get
reintroduced having wiped them out
because they um um compete with us for
for food which is because they might eat
some of the livestock and everywhere you
go on Earth with only one or two very
small exceptions um large predators are
driven um to Extinction or to the brink
of Extinction at the behest of livestock
Farmers you don't have the trees growing
on these farms uh there was a another
metaanalysis looking at a 100 papers um
and found out that for all major
ecological groups gilds of of of
wildlife um every single one suffers
from having Livestock on the land except
for detrit ofor animals which eat done
all the other groups suffer they all
improve when you take the livestock off
the land so this idea that you can
square the circle you we can have our
beautiful picture of the cattle and the
Sheep grazing on the land and you can
have thriving ecosystems it exists in
picture books it exists in in our image
of farming but actually what the numbers
show is something very different and and
you know Patrick he paints a beautiful
picture but the problem is we are
dealing in pictures when we desperately
need to be dealing in numbers we need to
become food numerate and just as with
climate issues you know we've slowly
become climate numerate we've begun to
do the maths we've begun to understand
how much fossil fuels we need to leave
in the ground if we're to avoid a
certain amount of global heating the
same has to happen with food otherwise
we're
cooked we was difficult for us to
imagine exactly how it would unfold but
we made a very big bet on deep learning
uh which is one of the primary tools
that is powering this new Revolution um
before anybody was involved in deep
learning so the the current chief
scientist and co-founder of open AI the
creators of chat GPT was one of our
inter turns uh back in 2011 Jeffrey
Hinton who was the subsequently became
the um one of the heads of AI at Google
and is known now as the Godfather of AI
recently in the Press worried about the
consequences he was our first adviser
our paid adviser I think his salary was
£25,000 a year to advise us so I think
three of the six co-founders of open AI
at some point passed through deep mind
either to give talks or were actually
members of the team so really is
incredibly about timing you know we got
the timing absolutely right we were way
ahead of the curve at that moment and
somehow we managed to hang on so you you
were there for a while and then let's
fast forward a bit um you can read the
rest of this in the book you you now
have co-founded and run inflection Ai
and you are creating an AI called Pi
which you can interact with if You' like
tell us what pi does so Pi stands for
personal intelligence and I believe that
over the next few years everybody is
going to have their own personal AI
there are going to be hundreds of
thousands of AIS in the world they'll
represent businesses they'll represent
Brands every government will have its
own AI every nonprofit every musician
artist record label everything that is
now represented by a website or an app
is soon going to be represented by an
interactive conversational intelligence
service that represents the B brand
values and the ideas of whatever
organization is out there and we believe
that at the same time everybody will
want their own personal AI one that is
on your side in your corner helping you
to be more organized helping you to make
sense of the world um it really is going
to function as almost like a chief of
staff all you know prioritizing planning
teaching supporting
supporting you so that sounds great um
what does it actually mean though in
practice cuz so often this conversation
about AI it's at this point then it
turns into the apocalyptic we're going
to end up you know wiping ourselves out
because there'll be some Rogue person
you know sitting in a garage somewhere
who will you know unleash a virus that
will kill us all so before we get to all
of that stuff in let's
say I don't know 5 years and you've said
within the next 3 to 5 years you think
AI will reach human level capability
across a variety of tasks perhaps not
everything but a variety so paint a
picture for us of what life will be like
in five years at 2028 I me first of all
will it be you and me here or will there
be the kind of Mustafa AI in
the okay let me let me just go back 10
years just to to give you a sense for
what has already happened and why the
predictions that I'll make I think are
plausible so the Deep learning
Revolution enabled us to make sense of
raw messy data so we could use AIS to
interpret the content of images classify
whether an image contains dogs or cats
what those pixels actually mean we can
use it to understand speech so when you
dictate into your phone and it
transcribes it and Records perfect text
we can use it to do language translation
all of these are classification t s
we're essentially teaching the models to
understand the messy complicated world
of raw input data well enough to
understand the objects inside that data
that was the classification Revolution
the first 10 years now we're in the
generative Revolution right so these
models are now producing new images that
you've never seen before they're
producing new text that you've never
seen before they can generate pieces of
music and that's because it's the flip
side of that coin the first stage is
understand understanding and classifying
if you like the second stage having done
that well enough you can then ask the AI
to say given that you understand you
know what a dog looks like now generate
me a dog with your idea of pink with
your idea of yellow spots or whatever
and that is an interpolation it's a
prediction of the space between two or
three or four Concepts and that's what's
produced this generative AI revolution
in all of the
modalities as we apply more computation
to this process so we're basically
stacking much much larger AI models and
we're stacking much much larger data the
accuracy and the quality of these
generative AIS gets much much better so
just to give you a sense of the
trajectory we're on with respect to
computation over the last 10 years every
single year the amount of compute that
we have used for The Cutting Edge AI
models has grown by 10x so 10x 10x 10x
10x 10 times in a row now that is
unprecedented in technology history
nowhere else have we seen a trajectory
anything like that over the next 5 years
We'll add probably three or four orders
of magnitude basically another thousand
times the compute that you see used
today to produce gbt 4 or the chat model
that you might interact with and it's
really important to understand that that
might be a technical detail or something
but it's important to grab sort of grasp
that because when people talk about gbt
3 or gbt 3.5 or gbt 4 the distance
between those models is in fact 10 times
compute it's not incremental it's
exponential and so the difference
between gbt 4 and gbt2 is in fact a 100
times worth of compute the largest
compute infrastructures in the world
basically to learn all the relationships
between all the inputs of all of this
raw data so when I went through Wall
Street uh interviews back in the 1980s
they were they were they were their own
strange event mainly designed to sort of
test your nerve I mean they do just
weird things like uh
um generally what they were try to is
make you as uncomfortable as possible
and see how you responded and um the the
the interviews that identify Sam bankman
fre is possibly very gifted uh in a way
that the high frequency Traders care
about
and these are the firms by the way these
firms I mean unless you're in Wall
Street or in finance you may never have
heard of these places Jan Street James
Street jump trading Tower research um
Susana Capital uh Citadel virtue these
are the names of the places and this is
and this is a phenomenon of the last 15
years that they have they are taking the
interesting risk in the markets now it's
no longer Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley that are doing this that these
firms are they are the ones who are
establishing Market market prices and
and in these places sums of money are
being made that dwarf the sums of money
that were made in their predecessors I
mean it used to be a big deal to make a
million dollars in a firm there are
people in these firms who make billions
of dollars um so Sam and the tests they
put you through and the kind of people
they're looking for a little different
social skills not important not at all
important it's it's what's important is
it's it's a math but it's not just a
mathness it's a math combined with an
ability to deal with messiness so it's
it's Sam bman freed good at chess good
at math camp but not the very best not
going to be a famous mathematician not
going to be a chess champion but if
instead you change chess so that every
move has to be done within 10 seconds
and every two minutes uh some voice
shouts a rule change so Queens become
pawns or pawns can fly or whatever that
it is it doesn't matter creating a kind
of semi chaotic environment that's the
environment that at least the the the
people who are recruiting for these
firms think you need to be good at in
order to to thrive um so and he also
appears to be willing to take risks
where other people might hesitate he
jumps in correct but you you have to be
able to make decisions where other
people might be paralyzed and he would
say I think this is true that the kind
of problems they give you tend to paral
tend to cause people just to not not
make decisions and they're looking for
people who will make decisions and make
them fairly quickly uh and so the um his
willingness to make the decisions was an
was an asset in this process um I mean
we could run we don't want to run
through any of these tests they're
incred they're incredibly Arcane what
they do to these and you look and you
say like how could how do you even think
about that problem if I mean one I mean
for example to to reduce to a
quantitative matter uh what's the
likelihood that I have a relative who
played professional baseball and to
think through that problem in a really
sophisticated way and do it quickly it's
one of the tests they put him through
and so and another way of thinking about
what they do is um learning how to
quantify things that you might think are
of as qualitative matters or qualitative
decisions he had the ability to do that
he he off the charts ability like when
he when he went through the the these um
interviews they would one of the firms
sto the interviews halfway through the
interviews and said you don't need to do
anymore you just outscored anybody this
year and his problem however is that
these tests and the problem these firms
have I think these tests do not filter
for any kind of social ability uh and
this is a person who to describe to
describe him is isolated doesn't fully
capture the the nature of the person um
this is a person who you know from a
very early age so when I ask him I mean
which you I would do would do with any
subject give me a little list of people
uh from the who knew you before the age
of 18 so I can just get a sense of what
your childhood was like he couldn't name
a person he his parents his brother was
off the list because his brother he
didn't have anything to do with his
brother and that I had to kind of dig
and dig and dig to find people who had
interaction with him before the age of
18 he felt he felt um uh first no real
feeling for people like in the presence
of people he didn't feel love he didn't
feel he said I didn't feel Pride I
didn't feel any of the things people
normally feel he said the thing I most
weirdly couldn't do is I couldn't make
facial expressions so when people were
interacting with me I wasn't giving they
they didn't know how to respond to me so
they just thought I was this weird thing
so he I don't go ahead you I was to say
he does at one time though talks about
talk about being depressed and I wonder
if that reflects the fact that he does
feel emotion but just perhaps not in the
way that you or I might I'm sure he
feels something he thinks but he his
self-identity was I don't understand
other I don't understand these feelings
I don't I don't have these feelings and
he um and he was ostracized all the way
through childhood less so at MIT because
MIT tends to collect these people who
are ostracized by everybody else when
they're in high school but he was some
recognition there so I mean but you know
he was the kind of person who even the
Nerds rejected because he was such a
nerd right there was no spot for this in
in even in even in a private Silicon
Valley High School where his classmate
is Steve job's son that you would think
that would there'd be plenty of people
who he could not relate to who could not
relate to him and they would Bond over
that but but but that's not what happen
I wonder though if it develops later on
just jumping forward for a moment into a
kind of arrogance because he tells you
at one point that he doesn't struggle to
read other problem other people his
problem is that people can't read him
and I there's a little bit of me that
thinks come on come on he was pretty
good at reading other people I you know
I I think he was surpr this is the this
is the part that doesn't fit the overall
picture that his astuteness about other
people um not always but better than you
would have imagined given how and the
point about other people reading him is
if he's not giving anything it's hard
right he when he is in college when he
starts to develop ambition to go to work
on Wall Street and he realizes that this
there's been no social filter but
eventually there's going to be problems
because he can't do the social thing he
gets a mirror and he starts practicing
how to smile and he's resentful about it
why do I need to grin when you say
something that's amusing isn't it enough
that I just listen but he forces himself
to learn these things and I think Rome
is this
extraordinary um pretense of power when
actually the guy in the middle closer
you get you see that he there's very
very little that he can do and that
leaves you the question and it leaves us
the question I think too is if the guy
the figurehead is not doing this who the
hell is and I in in Rome I that is
almost impossible I think to pin down I
mean what we see is we see a um two
things simultaneously we see the Roman
Emperor if they're good at it performing
the rituals of
power and we see people on the
outside the critics at least worried
actually that all that the Roman Emperor
is is an actor and I that doesn't seem
to me to be too far from some of our
anxieties I mean I'm not a you know I I
I'm not wanting to attack Rishi sunak
here but um I think one place where we
saw that was when he went out just to
demonstrate the British populist that we
were all in it together with fuel prices
you know and he was filling up a smaller
car than he had ever owned using a
petrol pump that he was clearly very
inexperienced at and not quite knowing
how to pay now at that point we
say is that guy is he is he just a bad
actor you know and where do we put the
boundary between you know the authentic
leader and the guy who's playing at it
and and it's it's it's fascinating
actually if you look at a lot of what's
Happening uh on Twitter x a lot of
what's happening with AI and um deep
fakes a lot of it is about exposing
apparent disconnects between who they
seem to be in the public and who they
really are and it's it's one of the real
tricks of the deep fakes so the was one
actually about Rishi sunak where um you
see him failing to pull a pint and a
woman standing behind him looking in
horror turns out this is untrue turns
out this is a faked up photo but it's
very very successful because it hits an
instinct we have that of course he
wouldn't be able to pull a pint and of
course the bar bar the lady behind the
bar would not prove it it's the same
with um a deep fake they just did on
Kama where they have a sort of apparent
sort of very crackly recording of him
shouting at an aid for dropping his iPad
notice these deep fakes are not really
Grand things they're not making Kama
give a speech he didn't give it's tiny
accidental Court moments and again a lot
of Mary's book is is about people trying
to discredit Empress with glimpses of
how they behave at the dinner table or
what kind of food they serve or this
sort of thing yeah all I mean I think in
the case of Nero um you know a lot of
these lurd anecdotes
have actually got much more bottom in
them about about an analysis of Empire
than most people ever realized I mean we
love the stories or classical historians
love the stories about you know Nero
going to the theater and of course he's
desperate to be an actor and he demeans
himself because he performs on stage and
oh he's he's so vain that he has the
theater doors locked so that no one can
leave the performance um until he's
finished you know and there wonderful
stories about women giving you've
actually done that tonight that is oh
that's true don't try to leave guys
don't try um you know women give birth
so hope there's no hope that's not going
to happen women give birth and and uh
others pretend to drop down dead so they
can be carried out
and and the these are great you're
laughing and I laugh and I think they're
wonderful anecdotes uh and but they're
more than that because actually what
they're saying is not just Nero was
crazy you know and look how vain he was
they're saying here is the
Emperor being an actor for real and what
does that tell us about how he normally
is is he ever not an actor the first
thing I have to acknowledge uh is that I
do my job not out of a sense of social
obligation not in order to make the
world a better place but because I love
doing it and I have a natural
inclination to go to places where people
think differently than I do and
especially where that involves some kind
of moral quality that I find
questionable people who I used to call
weird like weird weekends I don't love
the word weird first of all it feels
judgmental second of all it feels
inexact like one man's weird is another
person's completely normal right
weirdness is to some extent in the eyes
of the beholder nevertheless the people
I speak to are quite weird and um I know
little contradictory but I think and I
think what it has to do with this is a
sort of sense of um them being either
loggerheads with the wider World by
violating so certain social norms they
work in Industries like the sex industry
or they're involved in extremism or or
or religious groups that feel like
they're on the edge of society they
they're apocalyptic in their thinking
and or they're in a loog ahads with
themselves because of choices they've
made so in some sort of sense of social
angst the qu the question was why do I
think it's important to do that because
after the fact having done it having
done it because I enjoyed doing it I've
realized there's real value in it and I
think what it comes down to is about is
challenging patterns of behavior that
you may have thinking about the world in
a different way I mean for me a lot of
the pleasure of it is just actually
reminding myself that my life is
complicated and and sort of fra as it
seems at times is less complicated and
fraud than the people I'm among but I
also think that in practicing habits of
Tolerance of listening of understanding
you can open up the world to a different
way of thinking and that you know that
we can all and and these qualities that
you can that you can think about things
in a different way you can connect in
unlikely ways with people who you might
think have nothing in common with you
and and thereby the world seems a
friendlier place what I sometimes say if
I can put it in a nutshell is the
weirdest thing about weird people is how
normal they
are and that wherever you go wherever
whatever extreme it may be whether
physically or in terms of ideology
you'll be more surprised by the
commonalities you find than by the
differences as much as I'd like to think
that I have techniques and that I I'm
kind of This brilliant um that I'm sort
of brilliant at adopting strategies for
connection really I'm I'm a lot of what
I do in so far as it connects with
people people is unsort like is actually
things that I come by by accident and
are probably qualities that in another
setting I might wish I didn't have I
actually think that my certainly when I
started a certain insecurity a certain
sense of
awkwardness almost felt like disarming
you know and I wasn't like oh I'm not
pretending to be awkward you know I
wasn't deliberately what I need is some
glasses like some ill fitting um clothes
like I I'll make sure there's like a
little bit of you know just rump like
make sure my jeans are a bit rumpled my
shoes look a bit you know like they've
seen better days it was very much the
case that I just had I was just being
who I was and that when that was you I
didn't have a great wardrobe and I was
really worried starting out when I
worked for Michael Moore I just thought
this is a nightmare I've been given a
network TV job on NBC in America you
know with no TV experience it was an you
know I just thought this is this is a
disaster you know I'm going to go out
there and I'm going to make a complete
fool of myself
and and and I was just I was frightened
I was fright when I went on that first
story that I did which was about
apocalyptic Cults um around around the
US I just thought how am I this they've
got the wrong guy and um and I think in
but but adventitiously if that's a word
I'll look that up later um
adventitiously uh what turned out to be
the case was those those qualities that
I thought were disabilities actually
ended up softening people up it's e it's
and and and in you know it's like by
being a little awkward it invites the
person in a bit more anyway I'm just
trying you know what is realness it's
just by being a bit real and and and I
know that sounds really basic and
probably banal but by being a bit real
and actually showing up and not making
it like how am I going to get the best
out of this person how am I going to
close the sale how am I going to you
actually just go in there thinking like
I really hope this person you know likes
me I hope this I hope this person um if
I I hope I can kind of make this run
smoothly and connect with this person
and and and that that realness infuses
every part of the
conversation